le coût de la vie c'est un grand moment
pour continuer de travailler pour bâtir
un canada meilleur
si tout le monde
est là voilà dans quelques minutes on
aura donc tous les chiffres pour jour
pour vous mesdames et messieurs dès que
le document est déposé à la chambre des
communes nous serons en mesure le huis
clos sera levé le secret budgétaire sera
levé pensera en mesure de vous donner
les faits saillants de ce deuxième
budget de madame fresnel le dépose dans
un contexte fort différent de la
dernière fois souvenez vous on était
encore en pleine pandémie
c'était des montants astronomiques que
l'on investissait pour pour relever le
pays de la pandémie pourrait aider les
canadiens qui avaient perdu leur emploi
etc on est dans un budget sortie de
crise on est dans un budget aussi qui a
à faire des choix mais quand même elle a
une marge de manoeuvre la milice des
finances ça tourne l'inflation aide le
gouvernement nuit aux citoyens mais
aident le gouvernement
on le disait pierre andré bouchard
saint-amand économie sébastien bovet que
l'on retrouve elle est dans une
générale fillion et madeleine jour
batteries sont jours alors vous êtes
sorti on les voit entrer aux communes on
va écouter
budget qui appuient les canadiens et
nous avons démontré au cours de la
pandémie que la meilleure manière de
s'assurer une relance économique c'est
en investissant dans les bonnes choses
pour les canadiens d'appuyer l'économie
d'appuyer des emplois verts d'appuyer le
logement c'est cela la responsabilité
fiscale et laissez-moi mettre l'accent
sur
le fait que ce budget fiscalement
responsable notre dette dessins
de manière constante le défi ses dessins
et aujourd'hui et pour l'avenir nous
avons le plus grand
ratio dette pib des pays du g7
oui on est là on continue d'appuyer les
familles on comprend que le coût de la
vie sont en train d'augmenter c'est pour
ça qu'on est là faut rêver avec le
logement on est là pour aider à créer
des emplois verts à créer de la
croissance économique on est aussi pour
aider avec le coût de la vie mais on le
fait
à pouvoir à créer de la croissance pour
les années à venir
très intéressant le commentaire et de
mme adam freeland et de monsieur trudeau
ils ont souligné huit fois plutôt qu'une
madeleine que ce budget gérald sébastien
et pierre andré ils ont ils au soulier
huit fois plutôt qu'une que saleh est
responsable comme budget parce que
politiquement ce qui est maintenant été
achetées dans l'opinion publique c'est
que là avec l'entente des clubs [ __ ] on
allait sortir la planche à billets qu'on
allait dépenser au maximum donc on a on
veut contrecarrer un peu cette image la
madeleine oui souvenez-vous dans la
première campagne électorale de justin
trudeau celle de 2015 avait promis des
petits déficits puis ensuite il s'était
finalement éloigné de cette promesse là
en parlant d'une nouvelle cible
budgétaire c'est-à-dire le ratio
dette/pib donc la taille de la dette par
rapport à la toute l'économie au complet
donc ça c'est son nouvel ancrage fiscale
quand on dit dans le jargon économique
et christoph rühl année justin trudeau
en ont parlé comme quoi le ratio dette
pib allait continuer de décroître patrie
je peux pas tout vous dire encore je ne
suis encore soumise à la loi du huis
clos je vais pouvoir vous donner plus de
détails tout à l'heure mais là je révèle
pas de secret il l'ont fait eux mêmes en
disant que cet ancrage fiscales seraient
respectés et christophe rien ne dit que
ce serait un budget qui serait
fiscalement responsable c'est une des
grandes demandes du parti conservateur
dans l'opposition officielle en disant
faut pas trop dépenser faut être sérieux
faut être prudent landes dans les
dépenses gérald je vais aller à vous
dans une seconde mais comme vous pouvez
pas dévoilé tous les chiffres je vais
demander sur ce même question car andré
bouchard saint-amand
c'est pas pour rien c'est pas on a voulu
télégraphié le fait que c'était pas un
buffet ouvert qu'on allait dépenser de
façon irresponsable on veut se battre
contre cette image là ben on va voir
bien sûr si le message politique
correspond à l'énoncé budgétaire
on va voir cet ajustement le à la levée
du huis clos rappelons aussi qu'un autre
façon d'être fiscalement responsable
c'est de hausser les revenus et ce
gouvernement là dans l'entente avec le
npd aussi mentionné l'idée qu'il
pourrait augmenter la charge fiscale des
des banques au canada et il faudrait en
fait voir à quel point cette cette
hausse de revenus là pourrait se
traduire en fait également dans la tente
ou dans la réduction plutôt difficile et
l'atteinte de l'équilibré budgétaire bon
giral en tout cas on veut que ça soit
bien dit que on n'a pas cassé le petit
cochon au complet ouais bah on est dans
un contexte économique favorable en il
faut dire la croissance économique est
forte présentement
quand vous prenez ce qu'on appelle le
pib nominal on est à 12 13% là vous
enlevez l'inflation et la croix vous
avez la croissance nette de l'économie
mais l'irs revenu rend très rapidement
présentement au gouvernement fédéral le
taux de chômage est extrêmement bas le
niveau d'inflation est élevé le prix du
pétrole faut-il le rappeler nous sommes
un pays de ressources le canada est
encore un pays de ressources et on l'a
prouvé encore 9 juillet on le faisait
hier avec le projet b du nord donc c'est
un pays qui compte encore sur le pétrole
le gaz naturel sur les ressources
naturelles et engrange énormément de
revenus donc madame free run arrive avec
la présentation de ce deuxième budget
dans un contexte économique qui lui est
favorable pour l'instant en tout cas on
verra dans les données que je vais vous
soumettre dans quelques instants jusqu'à
quel point elle a pu utiliser sa marge
de manoeuvre on va on va entendre
madame fernet à quelques secondes à
quelques secondes de commencer son
discours du budget je rappelle mesdames
émission c'est son deuxième budget on va
écouter les premières minutes et ensuite
on vous donne mesdames et messieurs tous
les chiffres
mais
monsieur le président alors à la suite
de l'ordre 83 je voudrais dépossédant
les deux langues officielles mais budget
de 20 22 dont les avis pour le faire
exploser dans ces documents au et
conformément au paragraphe
83 faire que deux je demande que l'étude
de ces motions soit inscrite à l'ordre
du jour
[Applaudissements]
tant qu il merci
mr speaker monsieur le président
nous nous souvenons tous de
se jeter en mars il y a environ deux
heures lorsque nos plans de voyage ont
dû être annulés lorsque nos enfants sont
rentrés de l'école et lorsque nous
allions à l'épicerie pour acheter des
produits hygiéniques
nous avons alors réalisé que ce virus
perturberait nos vies mais peu d'entre
nous ont imaginé jusqu'à quel point cela
y règne
pour quelle durée cela dit nous voici
nous avons plié sans nous briser les
canadiens ont tout fait ce qui leur a
été demandé et même plus et donc à tous
les canadiens à vous tous j'aimerais
commencer en vous remerciant
alors voilà mesdames et messieurs
pendant que la ministre va faire la
lecture de son deuxième budget général
dont il est en mesure maintenant de
donner les faits saillants de ce
deuxième budget on vous écoute alors
déficit de 50,2 milliards 800 millions
pour le budget qui est présenté pour
2022 23 c'est un peu plus faible que ce
qui avait été prévu dans la mise à jour
économique patrice 52 milliards 800
millions pour la simple et bonne raison
que la croissance économique est
tellement forte qui a à peu près une
marge de manoeuvre supplémentaire qui
s'est ajoutée de 50 milliards de dollars
par rapport à la mise à jour économique
donc on révise en forte baisse le
déficit budgétaire 21-22 qui devait être
de 145 qui finalement 214 et pour 22 23
52 milliards 800 millions mais toujours
pas de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire 8
milliards 400 millions c'est le plus
loin qu'on va en 2000 26 27 pour le
déficit budgétaire la grande nouveauté
aujourd'hui et ce qu'ils probablement ce
qui va marquer les esprits c'est la
création du compte d'épargné libre
d'impôt pour l'achat d'une première
propriété alors vous pourrez mettre
jusqu'à 40000 dollars dans ce compte
d'épargné
brrr d'impôt 8000 $ par année en
cotisations pour les gens qui veulent
acheter une première propriété 8000 $
par année jusqu'à 40000 au maximum et
quand vous mettez de l'argent là-dedans
c'est déductible d'impôt comme on le
fait avec un reér où on va reporter de
l'impôt à plus tard et les retraits ne
sont pas imposables comme un celi donc
ça c'est un gros changement c'est un
gros changement c'est encore plus
avantageux c'est comme le meilleur des
deux mondes entre le reer et le celi
beaucoup plus avantageux que le rap le
régime d'accès à la propriété et
l'objectif ici c'est vraiment de
permettre aux ménages d'avoir accès à la
propriété ça coûte de plus en plus cher
acheté une propriété au canada l'accès à
la propriété se réduit de plus en plus
et le gouvernement fédéral considère
qu'il faut aller très loin sur le point
sur le plan fiscal avec une mesure comme
celle là pour permettre aux canadiens
d'avoir accès davantage à une première
propriété il ya d'autres mesures qui ont
été annoncées également pour acheter une
première propriété et un crédit
l'innovation va doubler également le
crédit à l'achat d'une première
propriété mais je vous dirais que sur
l'accès à la propriété ya cela ensuite
toujours dans l'immobilier il ya la
construction de logements il manque de
logement au canada le gouvernement
annonce la fin de la construction de
cent mille logements avec un
investissement de 4 milliards de dollars
sur cinq ans cent mille logements c'est
beaucoup mais c'est peu par rapport aux
besoins du canada la banque scotia
identifié que ça prenait 1 million 800
mille logements au canada pour arriver
au niveau du g7 récemment donc encore du
travail à faire 6000 logements
abordables 1 milliard 500 millions sur
deux ans et de l'aide pour les personnes
en difficulté qui ont des difficultés à
trouver un logement abordable un
paiement unique de 500 $ ses 475
millions de dollars qui sera versée
cette année est toujours dans le monde
de l'immobilier il faut calmer la
spéculation immobilière
donc on rappelle que ce qui est déjà
sorti hier soir des restrictions aux
acheteurs étrangers aux investisseurs
étrangers qui font de la spéculation
immobilière au canada pour une période
de 2 et les flip immobilier ce qu'on
appelle en français la revente
précipitée ou la revente rapide à
l'intérieur de 12 mois un impôt sera
chargé imposition complète sur les
bénéfices si vous voulez jouer à ce jeu
de faire de la revente précipité à
l'intérieur de 12 mois ça c'est à partir
du 1er janvier 2023 fort intéressant
donc la partie immobilière c'est ce qui
va ressortir peut-être comme faits
saillants gerald de ce budget est là la
question puis on va faire les autres
points mais la question que les gens
vont se poser c'est est-ce que le celi
par exemple ne va pas
améliorer l'accès à la propriété oui
mais donc faire tourner la roue encore
plus vite et faire monter les prix
l'objectif c'est puisque les prix sont
en croissance comment vous aider les
gens à accéder au marché ce qui va
calmer la hausse des prix c'est la
hausse des taux d'intérêt de la banque
du canada qui est engagée la banque du
canada paie sur l'accélérateur pour
augmenter les taux d'intérêt donc le
gouvernement se dit d'un côté la banque
du canada joue son rôle en tentant de
calmer l'inflation est la hausse
éventuellement et et en coïncidence la
des prix de l'immobilier
mais nous de notre côté comment on peut
augmenter l'offre donc construction
davantage de logements et augmenter
l'accès à la propriété c'est en tout cas
l'un des outils qui est présenté
aujourd'hui par madame freeman et puis
ottawa annonçait aussi c'était
télégraphie en régime de soins dentaires
gratuits résultats de l'entente avec le
npd oui et on a fait du copier coller
avec l'entente je vous dirais la à
partir de 2022 soins dentaires gratuits
pour les jeunes de moins de 12 ans et à
partir de 2023 pour les moins de 18 ans
pour les aînés pour les personnes
handicapées et on parle ici des ménages
dont le revenu annuel est en bas de 90
mille dollars par année donc c'est
important c'est quand même circonscrit
on veut amener un soin
supplémentaires accessibles à la
population qui est absolument essentiel
dans la vie des soins dentaires gratuits
ce qui est annoncé également je vais
détailler d'autres mesures les véhicules
électriques qui intéresse à peu près
intéresse beaucoup de gens on prolonge
les incitatifs jusqu'en mars 2000 25
après mars 2005 on verra si la demande
est vraiment très très au rendez vous
mais on considère au gouvernement qu'il
faut encore soutenir alors que le
gouvernement du québec a réduit ses
rabais le gouvernement du canada dit il
faut en faire davantage
donc on maintient le rabais à 5000 $ sur
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique on
élargit l'admissibilité aux
fourgonnettes aux camions et aux
véhicules utilitaires sport et on ajoute
également des incitatifs pour l'achat de
véhicules zéro émission moyens et lourds
550 millions sur quatre ans à transports
canada pour tenter de développer un
nouveau programme
on annonce qu'on avait déjà laissé
entendre c'est à dire la création d'un
crédit d'impôt pour le captage et le
stockage de carbone donc un crédit de
37,5 à 60% pour les entreprises qui vont
capter qui vont stocker du carbone c'est
une technologie qui demande énormément
d'investissement
ça coûte cher c'est loin d'être la seule
ou même diront certains la bonne
solution pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais le
gouvernement compte notamment sur ce
crédit d'impôt qui est annoncé dans ce
budget aujourd'hui sur le captage et le
stockage du carbone est également la fin
des déductions fiscales sur les dépenses
d'exploration dans le pétrole le gaz et
le charbon c'est le début du
commencement de l'élimination des
subventions au secteur des hydrocarbures
donc les déductions fiscales dans les
impôts de ses sociétés pétrolières et
gazières notamment sur des dépenses
d'exploration le gouvernement a décidé
de mettre fin à cela mais le captage et
le stockage comme ça coûte une fortune
ce qu'on mettait dans l'exploitation
comme crédit d'impôt à ed ouais on le
transfère en fait en technologies pour
rendre l'industrie moins polluants alors
on veut effectivement éliminer les
subventions
amener un plafond d'émissions pour
l'industrie pétrolière et aider
l'industrie et les autres industries
pour seulement pétrolière a capté à
stocker du carbone dans les airs ou dans
le sol
c'est une avancée technologique pas de
doute là dessus mais c'est encore très
peu utilisée dans le monde présentement
donc si on veut atteindre nos objectifs
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
en 2030 ça va pas passer par le stockage
et le captage et le stockage et le
captage c'est une petite partie de la
solution le travail est beaucoup plus
large beaucoup plus profond pour le
reste la défense on avait beaucoup parlé
alors alors 7 milliards 200 millions de
dollars supplémentaires sur cinq ans on
est loin du compte de ce qui est attendu
je pense par l'otan et par les pays
membres de l'otan qui évoquait qui qui
demandent en fait 2% du produit
intérieur brut en ce moment' à 1,4 donc
cet ajout supplémentaire il est là pour
renforcer la défense pour et city c'est
écrit dans le budget on veut respecter
notre engagement avec le temps on veut
changer aussi la culture dans les forces
armées canadiennes du temps alors 7
milliards 200 millions sur cinq ans puis
on ajoute également 500 millions de
dollars supplémentaires pour l'aide
militaire à l'ukraine et un milliard de
dollars disponibles en prêt pour
l'ukraine si l'ukraine a besoin bien sûr
de sommes supplémentaires au cours des
prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois il ya des hausses et des baisses
d'impôts pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui hausses d'impôts pour les
banques et les compagnies d'assurance
pour les banques par exemple il y aura
un impôt de 15 % sur tout ce qui est
supérieur à 1 milliard de dollars en
2021 donc on appelle ça un dividende
spécial puis on augmente le taux
d'imposition de 15 à 16 5% sur les
revenus de plus de 100 millions de
dollars pour les banques et les
compagnies d'assurance en baisse l'impôt
de plusieurs pme ya des pme qui n'ont
pas accès aux taux 9% qui est le plus
bas sont à 15 pour ça on va élargir
l'accès du taux d'imposition à 9 % pour
les pme aucun fond de croissance de 15
milliards pour aider à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
faire la transition climatique à
rétablir les chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est un fonds important pour le
gouvernement ce que le gouvernement va
nous dire aujourd'hui beaucoup madame
swing va le dire
ce fonds là pour objectif d'aider
l'innovation la productivité l'avenir
économique du canada est un crédit aussi
pour l'exploration de minéraux critique
avec toute une stratégie sur huit ans
pour développer les minéraux critique
ces minéraux critique c'est comme le
lithium par exemple on trouve dans les
batteries pour les véhicules électriques
on mise beaucoup beaucoup sur les
minéraux critiques et je termine avec le
montant de la dette
1161 milliards de dollars au 31 mars
2022 on est à 700 milliards je vous le
rappelle avant le début de la pandémie
alors 1161 milliards ça veut dire 46 5%
du pib et l'objectif et 41,5 en 2000 26
27 la dette par rapport à l'économie
patrice va baisser plus rapidement
qu'attendu parce que la croissance
économique est forte parce que
l'inflation est élevée ça permet au
gouvernement de miser plus que jamais
sur ce fameux ratio dette/pib pour son
ancrage son ancrage budgétaire son
ancrage fiscale il aurait pu gerald mais
corrigez moi si je me trompe mais en 26
27 vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure 8,4
milliards je crois le déficit on aurait
pu avec fougue et diers dit fier de 0 à
ce moment alors oui exactement certains
le sait et irait à zéro parce que sur
une économie 2300 milliards quand vous
avez 8 milliards de réussite vous êtes à
peu près à l'équilibré budgétaire mais
il ya comme une allergie chez les
libéraux a prononcé les mots équilibre
budgétaire et ça demeure donc on frôle
l'équilibré budgétaire mais on n'y va
pas on reste dans le rouge en raison de
roches mais qui aujourd'hui en fait
qu'on fait c'est qu'on constate que de
la marge de manoeuvre par rapport à ce
qui était prévu dans le budget l'an
passé et par rapport à la mise à jour
économique compte tenu de la croissance
économique on utilise une partie de la
marge de manoeuvre mais quand même le
déficit va baisser de façon plus
importante qu'attendu dans les
prochaines années que ce qui était prévu
dans la mise à jour économique donc on
reste dans le rouge le celi ça c'est
fort important violée dans moins de 12
ans pour les familles de 90 mille
dollars et moins il ya la défense et il
ya on va chercher des revenus
supplémentaires chez les banques etc
madrid dans quelle mesure cette entente
avec le npd a été déterminant bon pour
les dents bien sûr est ce que pour le
reste on y voit des traces on se demande
s il ancre de ce budget serait en encre
orange une matrice orange npd pas
vraiment vous parler
du programme dentaire ça c'est important
et c'était d'ailleurs le plus gros gain
du npd lors ce qu'ils avaient conclu une
entente avec le parti libéral mais sinon
on ça ressemble à un budget qui est
plutôt libérale par exemple les
promesses en logements cela faisait déjà
partie du programme électoral du parti
libéral moi je dirais pas tu risques
cette entente là a surtout permis au
gouvernement d'avoir du temps devant lui
on n'est pas face à un budget qui est
électoraliste on n'est pas face à un
budget où on sent le gouvernement
nerveux à devoir donner des bonbons à
droite à gauche en disant on veut
peut-être aller en campagne électorale
sous peu non on a vraiment l'impression
qu'on me dise même sur la croissance à
moyen et à long terme et christiane dans
un point de presse sous embargo qu'il a
donné dans le huis clos et des lorsqu'on
parle de croissance économique du pays
généralement c'est parce qu'ils aient
nécessairement le plus sexy c'est là je
sais ce sont mes mots là les gens lèvent
les yeux au ciel mais il ya vraiment un
effort dans ce budget là pour parler de
croissance à moyen et long terme parce
que le gouvernement reconnaît que c'est
un problème en disant que même lot c'est
d'ailleurs en mesurer que de 2020 à 2060
lorsqu'on prend la moyenne c'est le
canada que le plus faible taux de
croissance moyen de tous les pays de
l'osce et des dons qu'il faut agir en ce
sens là et le logement c'est vu comme
une mais une une façon d'accroître la
croissance en disant s'il ya des
nouveaux travailleurs qui arrivent au
pays il faut qu'ils aient des logements
ce genre mais on rappelle aux gens cent
mille logements c'est beaucoup moins que
le npd
voulait dans son programme à lui je
m'étais moi c'était quand même le
programme ou dans l'est du côté du parti
libéral et du côté du npd on voulait
agir là dessus et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on peut entendre un extrait de cette
de ce point de presse de christoph rühl
entre sur le logement justement
au cours des dix prochaines années nous
doubler le nombre de logements que nous
construirons au canada nous rendrons
le marché plus équitable pour les
canadiens et canadiennes notamment en
interdisant l'achat de propriétés par
des intérêts étrangers
notre plan de logement rendra la vie
plus à vos aux abords table et il sera
également bénéfique pour notre économie
donc voilà pas très sinon on est quand
même assez prudents nous donne le temps
de réfléchir à la façon d'investir
notamment en défense lorsqu'on disait il
ya 7 milliards de nouveaux
investissements ça se rend pas à 2% du
pib s'en fait à terme ans en cinq ans ce
sera plutôt 1,5 pour cent du pib des
défenses en dépenses de défense donc on
ne change pas le
change pas la courbe totalement dans la
défense est-ce que les f 35 sont là
dedans ou pas oui parce que c'était déjà
inclus patrice si je n'abuse était déjà
prévue dans les prévisions budgétaires
passe très bien 88 f 35 de lockheed
martin qu'on avait annulé repris à nous
lire prix là on va les acheter
finalement merci à tout de suite on
retrouve le chef du npd jack médecine
bonjour monsieur singh bonjour monsieur
est ce que vous vous retrouvez tous les
éléments que vous vouliez dans le budget
les éléments qu'on a utilisé notre
pouvoir d'obtenir sont là donc ça veut
dire une investissement pourrait les
légions avec les soins dentaires
commençons avec les enfants moins de 12
ans donc on est on est et si c'est bon
de voir sa légion des mondes et dead et
on a utilisé notre pouvoir de réaliser
cette aide aussi avec le logement
c'était une élément prioritaire dans
notre entente aussi et on est forcé le
gouvernement d'augmenter les
financements aussi changer les
définitions de croix et abordable donc
ces changements et les investissements
sont vraiment importants et c'était un
élément essentiel dans notre entente
donc on est on est fier de voir ça mais
l'approché avec l'environnement partout
qu'ils m'ont après ce qu'elle a vu jack
sassi où on a des grandes inquiétudes de
fait qu'ils ont augmenté les subventions
4 lierre au lieu de les éliminer c'est
une mauvaise décision et on va continuer
de critiquer ça et on va continuer des
possibles plus d'impôts plus les gens
bons et vous dites que le programme
dentaire pour les familles de 90 dollars
arrêts - 12 ans la gratuité pour les 12
ans et moins vous dites ça valait le
coup de se donner aux libéraux si je
peux dire
c'était quelque chose de vraiment
important qu'on en ait parlé avec les
québécois et québécoises avec les
canadiens qui ne viennent il était clair
ils ont besoin dead et ils ont dit qu et
on ne peut pas soigner nos dents donc
c'est vraiment un programme essentiel
des plus grands expansion de notre
système de santé publique dans une
génération donc ça c'est quelque chose
vraiment importants ont aussi avec les
investissements dans le logement
abordable ça c'est aussi vraiment
important oui merci que je signe ça mais
je sais que les libéraux leur effet le
logement versée dans leur programme ou
si nous si on voit leur définition de ce
qui est abordable ce n'étaient pas les
mêmes choses et l'heure par rapport leur
définition
2500 $ par mois était abordable à
montréal avec ce changement on est
réduit c'était montre vraiment une
grande réduit à neuf sont presque 70
dollars ça veut dire une grande
réduction de ce qui est abordable ça
c'est vraiment un grand des éléments
dans cette entente on a la force et le
moment de faire et c'est maintenant dans
le bouger vous vivez bien avec
l'augmentation des dépenses militaires
c'était quelque chose qui on a révisé et
on a dit que on est d'accord avec l'idée
d'investir à pour donner les outils
nécessaires pour nos forces canadiens de
faire le travail que on les dit de faire
donc ça c'est important on a reconnu
l'importance et ça mais on a dit que les
deux sens
que les taux a demandé ici dit ce n'est
pas quelque chose là qu'on était
d'accord avec et ça c'est écrit free
tréflez dont le bouger ouais ils sont à
1,5 baie du nord hier l'annoncé du feu
vert pour le projet pétrolier baie du
nord
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous dites
pilar vous avez les mains liées vous
allez dire je suis con mais vous êtes
presque un libéral maintenant au niveau
tactique là nous pas du tout on est
toujours un parti d'opposition on est
contre cette décision on est contre
l'idée de deux
expansions de nous de les déloger
fossiles on pense que c'était une
mauvaise décision
si on a eu une vote sur cette question
on aurait voté contre et on est aussi
contre l'idée d'investir plus d'argent
dans les subventions ça ils vont être au
diable donc on va continuer de critiquer
critiquer ça avec le report de j'ai
accès important continue de faire tout
ce qu'on peut faire face à la crise
climatique est bien je sais combien il
reste le budget là vous appuyer pour
combien trois budgets
oui à jusqu'à 2025 jacques médecin chef
du npd merci beaucoup merci vous vous en
prie de la prochaine
alors oui voilà mais ceux-ci madeleine
juste un petit mot là dessus évidemment
lui il doit se dire satisfaits y allait
d'un but à gaza l'assurance médicaments
c'est pas tout de suite non c'est ça ce
qui est particulier avec l'entente
patrice c'est que pour la première année
c'était très clairement défini ce qui
devait être inclus dans l'entente les
soins dentaires il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de détails prévu dans cette
alliance npd parti libéral pour ce qui
est des prochaines années alors ça va
être un peu plus compliqué il va falloir
négocier probablement entre le parti
libéral et le npd entre autres pour
l'assurance médicaments le gouvernement
libéral avait déjà dit qu'ils voulaient
a prolongé ce programme là où et étendre
ce programme là mais comment exactement
ça reste vraiment beaucoup à voir et on
sait qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de détails
dans la grande qui a été rendu public
mais c'est pas le plus coûteux un
patrice faut dire lasser ses 5 milliard
300 millions sur cinq ans ni soins
dentaires gratuits et ensuite c'est 1
milliard 700 millions par la suite
l'assurance médicaments vont coûter
beaucoup plus cher à installer et
instaurer installé dans l'ensemble du
canada pierre andré bouchard saint-amand
commentaire général qu'est ce qui vous a
qu'est ce qui vous frappe dans ce budget
d'abord les annonces qui sont faites en
matière de logement semble beaucoup plus
ciblée sur hong kong pour objectif on
pourrait dire de
répondre à la demande la hausse de coût
par rapport à la demande ceci dit si on
regarde les restrictions ou les
augmentations du côté de l'offre par
opposition aux mesures qui sont mises
l'avant comme le celi
quantitativement le celi devrait
l'emporter donc on peut s'attendre à
terme à des augmentations de prix qui
vont être induits en fait par les
mesures qui sont annoncées vous dites ça
va augmenter la frénésie des prix on est
en train de dire aux gens on vous donne
de l'argent pour acheter davantage alors
assurément il ya des vendeurs de
propriété qui vont vouloir tirer profit
de 7,6 liquidités supplémentaires là et
ça va se manifester effectivement par
des augmentations prix à terme très bien
on va aller merci rester là je vais les
faire réaction du parti conservateur
gérard deltell députée de louis saint
laurent et là je deltell vous m'attarder
oui je vous attends excusez moi je veux
tirer mon masque parce que sinon ça
aurait été un peu y'a pas de souci
d'argent sur moi monsieur deltell
réaction première réaction j'imagine
vous trouvez qu'il trouve d'epargne va
écouter c'est un budget et des mâts qui
porte la signature de justin trudeau
mais de plus en plus la signature du npd
c'est un couvent et reste un budget qui
finalement nous on avait trois cibles
principales qu'il fallait tout à fait
réglé avec une approche qui aurait été
positif pour les contribuables
malheureusement nos postes n'y a pas de
plan pour contrer l'inflation actuelle
de pas de plan pour contrôler les
dépenses et il n'y a pas d'action
immédiate immédiate pour aider
directement les gens qui veulent avoir
accès là la propriété soit pour nous
oui c'est un plat mais immédiatement à
ce que ça peut aider immédiatement les
gens avoir accès non et c'est pour ça
que oui on peut là par rapport à ça mais
ce plan là se déploie sur plusieurs
années alors que la crise avait
immédiatement pour ceux qui nous
écoutent actuellement et qui rêve
d'avoir une maison que ce soit des
jeunes familles ou des personnes qui
veulent avoir accès à la propriété pour
la première fois de leur vie peu importe
leur travail et me disent qu'aujourd'hui
non aujourd'hui ça change rien 10e c'est
dommage et de dire non aux étrangers
pour deux ans que ça va pas aider ça va
pas enlever des joueurs dans certains
marchés ben c'est des choses qu'on se
proposait déjà depuis un bon moment
alors c'est sûr que c'est un élément
maintenant est ce que c'est ce qui va
faire en sorte que chez nous par exemple
dans la région de québec les gens vont
pouvoir accès à une maison alors qu'on
sait qu'il ya cinq ans à peine écouté
deux fois moins cher c'est pas
nécessairement ce qui va changer la
donne mais est ce que pour être franc
vous vous attendiez à davantage de
dépenses que ça est-ce qu'il ya pas eu
ce coup de frein parce que 26 27 on
arrive quasiment du 7-0 là j'allais me
faisais à 8,4 mais est-ce qu'il ya
autant de dépenses que ce que vous aviez
craint d'abord sur les prévisions
budgétaires des déficits potentiel c'est
pour moi la sécabilité zéro chance que
trouvez moi un budget que prévu le
déficit 5 ans ou trois ans à vannes puis
on va vous gagnez un voyage qui
insistait 29 là parce que c'est
impossible et encore moins avec ce
gouvernement actuel qui n'ont
strictement aucun respect pour la parole
donnée sur les petits difficile tony
blair 2015 ces trois petits déficits et
0 en 2019 pour 30 août qui ont fait
alors ce chiffre là pour moi n'existe
pas la réalité par exemple qui existe
c'est que les revenus du gouvernement
ont été de 40 milliards de plus mais ça
vient tout cet argent là ça vient de
l'inflation parce que les textes ont été
plus élevées en réseau le retour sur les
textes étaient plus élevés en raison
l'inflation savez l'argent du
gouvernement le gouvernement qu'il le
sait les contribuables doivent aller
chercher dans les poches et on l'a vu
avec la hausse de l'inflation de 5,7
pour ça résultat mais les textes ont des
villes canadiens ont versé plus de tact
et c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
gouvernement plus d'argent que le
gouvernement est que plus un seul y
contribuer en au moins dans leur poche
vous auriez souhaité un comme un peu à
québec un chèque quoi ou un transfert
direct pour vous mais moi oui ben kemoun
ce qu'on a demandé si on la demandait
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines c'était
que l'augmentation de la taxe libération
de carbone qui entre en vigueur le 1er
avril dernier donc vendredi dernier que
cette augmentation l'homme ne soit pas
appliquée au moins se seraient donné un
peu d'oxygène serait donner un break aux
contribuables canadiens mais non le
gouvernement de l'opo fait et maintient
des textes mêmes ancrés certaines
nouvelles alors résultats mais les gens
ont moins d'argent dans leurs poches et
six gouvernements plus d'argent parce
que les citoyens non moins dans leur
poche le fruit de l'entente depuis il ya
eu beaucoup de blagues fait là sur un
budget mauvais que ce sera le fruit de
l'entente d'entre eux des députés
libéraux si le programme dentaire pour
les 12 ans et moins pour les familles
qui ont 90 mille dollars et moins de
revenus c'est pas une bonne chose au
canada qu on off le dentiste gratuit à
ses famille locke en arrachent on sait
que déjà des gens qui occupait que l'on
par rapport à ce programme là parce
qu'on sait qu'il est évidemment c'est
une responsabilité à la base provinciale
ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi puis je
parle encore avec des gens de l'est qui
sont dans le monde de la dentisterie
qu'il disait que la plupart des gens
plus de la moitié dans certains camps
même 75% des gens ont ce type
d'assurance que l'on donne un coup de
pouce aux personnes qui ne l'ont pas ça
votre soi mais c'est pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement fédéral
c'est une responsabilité qui incombe aux
provinces quick est ce que les provinces
demandent elles c'est d'avoir plus de
somme que l'on voit pas du tout dans le
budget actuel alors c'est un choix que
le gouvernement fait ottawa du
gouvernement npd libéral maintenant dans
cette gestion dans cette gouvernance
l'autre le dire ottawa c'est ce qui doit
se faire pour les provinces mais c'est
pas là proches que nous nous des toiles
bien rapport à ça jordan tel député du
parti conservateur de
louis-saint-laurent merci c'est moi qui
va
voir alors voilà geneviève tellier qui
s'ajoute à notre panel bonjour geneviève
et mis en musique bonjour mya mya un
petit mot commentaires synthèse sur ce
budget mais en fait moi je trouve que
c'est rassurant ils ont été capables de
concilier plusieurs objectifs qui
étaient qui allait dans tous les sens
mais pourquoi ils ont été capables à
cause de cette inflation qui nous
dérange tant qu'homme citoyens
qui rapporte énormément de revenus si on
regarde sur six ans c'est 90 milliards
de plus dans les coffres de l'état donc
ils ont été capables de réduire sur la
même période le déficit leur cumulatif
de 2 50 milliards par rapport à ce qui
était prévu en décembre dernier donc ces
immenses comme comme amélioration mais
sa cause d'inflation époque parce que
notre croissance économique de pib réel
vaut mieux c'est purement un effet de
l'inflation mais ça leur donnait
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre parce que
moi je trouve que c'est quand même un
budget qui est axé sur la croissance
économique la productivité l'innovation
il ya énormément mesure aussi pour
faciliter les dossiers d'immigration et
et paiera donc on pense à la mairie
d'oeuvre on pense à l'économie verte
beaucoup mais aussi on ne lit soins
dentaires on a des mesures pour
l'habitation pour la réconciliation avec
les autochtones donc
ont-ils été responsable n'y a pas ce que
regardent avant d'entrer à la chambre
des communes le premier ministre voulait
souligner le fait que attention le jeu
c'est un budget qu'on veut quand même
malgré les dépenses responsable et il a
votre avis responsable mais tout est une
question d'attentes et les attentes
étaient tout le monde s'attendait à
énormément de dépenses et puis les
libéraux nous ont habitués à énormément
de dépenses depuis qu'ils sont au
pouvoir et donc dans ce contexte là oui
je trouve que c est fiscalement
responsable parce que le poids de la
dette et dans 25 26 sec autour de 42 43
% on prévoyait 49% donc sa baisse de
façon plus importante puis 8 milliards
de déficit on est presque à l'équilibré
qu'on regarde dehors de nos jeunes
auraient pu mettre géraud pis ils
attendent le prochain au plus près de la
tête de la prochaine campagne geneviève
tellier qu'est ce que ça nous dit sur
les luttes à venir dans cette fédération
ah ça c'est intéressant premièrement
mais il ya les gens qui sont absents de
ce budget là les gens qui vont trouver
que rien pour eux il ya les provinces
alors il ya vraiment rien pour les
provinces certaines provinces vont être
contentes par exemple celles qui veulent
un peu gardé leur la propre chasse
gardée mais d'autres vont vouloir avoir
plus de transferts alors toute la
question des transferts en santé
l'augmentation à 95 % de la part du
gouvernement fédéral s'est pas l'appui
on ouvre même pas la porte pour ça
et donc cette idée moi je trouve que
c'est un budget qui est très
centralisateur jusqu'à un certain point
les deux seules mesures qui vont un peu
dans les champs de compétence des
provinces c'est le logement puis c'est
les soins dentaires mais à part ça on
reste vraiment dans le champ de
compétence fédérale on parle beaucoup
par exemple d'aider la chaîne
d'approvisionnement ballon fait
référence aux transports ont fait
référence aux exportations importations
à l'immigration donc très fédéral comme
budget puis ça faisait longtemps qu'on
en n'avait pas vu de ce type là alors
pour moi c'est une des caractéristiques
marquantes du budget et on laisse à la
négociation politique le soin de faire
avancer le dossier de les transferts en
santé
oui mais on donne très peu de détails
c'est comme autre chose on verra jaillir
de trudeau oui mais ce trou d'où vient
de signer ces ententes pour les services
de garde ce qui était quand même très
gros morceau est peut-être qu'il va
devoir signer aussi des ententes avec
l'assurance médicaments on verra comment
il va négocier ça mais pour monsieur
trudeau sa logique c'est d'y aller à la
pièce alors on va négocier une province
après l'autre puis finalement à la fin
on voit tout aller les chercher comme on
a fait avec l'ontario la semaine passée
pour les services de garde donc c'est un
peu ce genre de fédéralisme qui se met
en place chez monsieur trudeau mais on
aborde pas dans le budget d'aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment centré sur qu'est ce que
le gouvernement fédéral peut lui-même
faire pour aider les canadiens à
combattre surtout le coût de la vie très
bien gérald c'est le moment de refaire
une synthèse donc un budget en rouge
encore déficit de 113 milliards de
dollars 20 21 22 on prévoit 52 pour 21
22 23 et on continue comme ça alors des
sites prévus de 52 milliards 800
millions pour 2022 23 avec pas
d'objectif pour retour pour le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire dans les
principales mesures qui sont annoncées
le compte d'épargné libre d'impôt pour
la première propriété la construction de
cent mille nouveaux logements 4
milliards sur cinq ans le programme de
soins dentaires gratuits plus de 5
milliards de dollars et 7 milliards de
100 millions sur cinq ans pour le
secteur de la défense la mesure phare
que les gens vont particulièrement
retenir aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ce
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt pour
l'achat d'une première propriété
vous êtes un ménage peu importe l'âge
que vous avez mais vous voulez acheter
une première propriété vous pouvez
mettre jusqu'à 8000 $ par année dans ce
compte d'épargné libre d'impôt jusqu'à
un total de quarante mille dollars et à
une occasion vous voulez faire l'achat
d'une propriété à chaque fois que vous
allez déposer de l'argent dans le celi
ce sera déductible d'impôt comme arrière
barrières commerciales là dessus
monsieur deltell nous disaient oui mais
quelqu'un qui veut demain matin
s'acheter une maison ça va prendre du
temps il faut accumuler de l'argent bien
sûr mais acheté une maison il faut se
rappeler quand même que c'est un achat
peut-être le plus important de sa vie
alors je sais on peut peut-être se dire
que on peut attendre quelques années met
un peu d'argent de côté l'objectif ici
est le cadeau fiscal il est double moi
je me rappelle quand monsieur harper
avait créé le celi de famille compte
d'épargné libre d'impôt on dirait cadeau
fiscal de monsieur flaherty de monsieur
harper parce que le compte d'épargné
libre d'impôt vous permet de mettre de
l'argent dans une boîte de fructifier de
voir cet argent a fructifié de le
retirer sans avoir à payer d'impôts mais
ici on ajoute 3 bonbons supplémentaire
dans la boîte en disant vous mettez de
l'argent vous le déduisez de vos impôts
et vous paierez jamais les impôts
finalement sur cette somme là parce que
quand vous allez retirer votre argent
ben et et même le rendement qui aura été
fait ce sera comme un celi les retraits
ne seront pas imposables donc c'est
quand vous étiez
c'est triplement avantageux c'est très
avantageux et s'est pas terminée parce
que si par exemple au bout de quinze ans
vous ne l'avez pas utiliser votre celi
première propriété ben vous prenez
l'argent puis vous le mettez dans votre
reér tout simplement sans impôt sans
impôts il ravira pas de charges
supplémentaires sur l'impôt quelqu'un
que nous miserons peut pas le tchad
j'entends les gens dire ah ben je vais
l'utiliser c'est vraiment destiné à
l'achat d'une première maison d'une
première propriété mais une première
propriété peut survenir un autre moment
dans sa vie quand vous n'êtes plus
propriétaire pendant plusieurs années
ça peut arriver à ce moment là mais en
principe si l'objectif c'est d'aider les
jeunes ménages ou les ménages dont ceux
comme ça à avoir accès à la propriété
les prix des maisons ont monté de 20 à
30 % depuis un an alors c'est rendu
extrêmement compliqué tous les indices
nous montrent que l'accès à la propriété
se réduit de plus en plus et ça j'ai
râlé ce qu'ils aiment et j'imagine comme
il il estime que ça leur coûte ça va
leur coûter combien ça c'est une mesure
qui est estimé à 700 quelques millions
725 millions de dollars si je me trompe
pas là c'est pas de mesures qui vont
nécessairement ça que j'aime aussi cher
non ça coûtera pas si cher au
gouvernement le gouvernement doit se
priver de certains revenus d'impôts avec
ce type de mesure comme il se prive de
revenus d'impôts avec le reér par
exemple ou avec le celi quand les gens
retirent leur leur somme mais ce qui va
falloir surveiller c'est que les
gouvernants les provinces vont devoir
s'harmoniser à cela eric girard va
s'harmoniser le rapport à peu près pas
le choix d' harmoniser cette mesure là
pour qu'on aide puisque on a deux
déclarations de revenus à faire le même
congé fiscal lorsqu'on fait ça au québec
très bien on poursuit
pour lever les faits saillants les dames
oui les dents donc les soins dentaires
c'est une mesure très importante qui va
toucher beaucoup de gens dès 2022 donc
dès cette année tous les ménages dont le
revenu annuel est inférieur à 90 milles
dollars dès 2022 les moins de 12 ans
soins dentaires gratuits et dès 2023 on
passe aux moins de 18 ans on ajoute les
aînés les personnes handicapées toujours
un revenu annuel de moins de 98 dollars
et je vous signale également que pour
les personnes qui gagnent moins de 70
milles la quote-part complet lorsqu'on
va chez le dentiste on n'aura plus à les
payer également donc c'est vraiment un
nouveau programme d'accès aux soins
dentaires autre fait saillant on a
beaucoup parlé de la défense on met de
l'argent peut être moins que certains ne
l'avaient pensé 7 milliards 200 millions
de dollars sur cinq ans le gouvernement
dit nous voulons respecter les priorités
les engagements du canada l'engagement
du canada à l'intérieur de le temps
c'est d'avoir des sommes en défense 2 2
% du pib d'une valeur de 2 % du pib donc
on n'est pas là on sera à peu près à 1
5% du produit intérieur brut la défense
au canada ces quelques si je me trompe
pas c'est autour de 30 milliards de
dollars donc on ajoute cette somme là au
cours des cinq prochaines années on
concentre cette année sur l'ukraine cela
dit 500 millions de dollars
supplémentaires en est en aide militaire
et 1 milliards disponibles en prêt à
l'ukraine gérald de merci beaucoup on se
retrouve au 17 heures à la salle et à la
radio merci pour tout il françois
blanchet le chef du bloc est avec nous
monsieur blanchet alors
j'imagine que vous avez cherché le mou
transferts aux provinces vous n'avez pas
trouvé en fait le québec et les
provinces demandent des transferts en
santé sans condition on a trouvé les
conditions mais poli transfert le
gouvernement s'est essentiellement vous
n'êtes pas bien bon si vous voulez
devenir meilleur vous pouvez nous parler
parce que nous aurons des meilleurs pour
vous autres dans une juridiction qui
sait des provinces et pour prendre celle
d'ottawa évidemment c'est une forme de
gifle au québec et aux provinces qu'est
ce que ça vous dit ça sur l'état
d'esprit du gouvernement trudeau dans
cette négociation parce qu'un enfant
quand même une sur les transferts en
santé il ya une espèce de loupe de de
volonté d'initier ce qui vaut être
conflictuelles entre ottawa et les
provinces et le québec d vous allez nous
céder une part de vos juridictions sanso
vous aurez pas d'argent et bien sûr
compte tenu de son alliance avec le npd
le gouvernement libéral se comporte
comme un gouvernement majoritaire qui
dit je vais prendre le temps je vais
peut être avoir le temps et je vais vous
imposer mes conditions parce que les
systèmes de santé à travers le canada le
système de santé au québec et exemple
sont en train d'étouffer d'écraser ils
ont besoin davantage d'argent le fédéral
dit ben vous allez continuer à partir
temps vous aurez pas accepter ma
juridiction dans votre champ de
compétence donc vous le voyez vous voyez
clairement il françois blanchet dans le
budget les effets de cette entente avec
le npd le côté pas de presse pour
annoncer les transferts aux provinces
voici un exemple vous dit ça donne une
idée que le budget était d'abord rédigé
tardivement puis un peu à la va vite
l'année dernière avant l'élection le
document du budget y étaient gros comme
ça celui de cette année il est gros
comme ça on est allé en élection parce
qu'il fallait prendre des décisions
majeures faire des investissements pour
développer puis arrive avec un petit
budget mais le petit budget contient
certains des éléments qui était souhaité
par le npd la maigreur des
investissements militaires en est un
exemple mais le plus gros bien sûr c'est
le programme de soins dentaires
programme de soins dentaires aussi la
partie québécoise comme ils l'ont fait
pour les garderies et versé à québec
sans condition c'est correct ouais je
mens si je devais de les conditions on
va le répéter urnes le parce que
évidemment on le voit venir gros comme
un train mais justement sur le fond
que des familles qui en arrachent
puissent avoir accès un dentiste gratuit
pour les 12 ans et moins moi je ne peux
pas être content sol ça s'appelle une
prise d'otages vous voulez de l'argent
pour les gens qui sont dans le besoin en
terme de santé en termes de santé
dentaire vous allez nous céder votre
compétence et votre juridiction pourquoi
parce que moi j'ai de l'argent vous en
avez - vous avez été
affaibli financièrement par la pandémie
donc je vous imposer mes conditions
c'est ça la volonté du fédéral et c'est
prendre en otage des gens qui disent oui
mais moi j'ai des besoins urgents pour
ma santé le procédé est odieux je suis
pas convaincu québécois vont acheter ça
le québec n'est pas un état vassal
d'ottawa le québec assistés juridiction
ses compétences et je suis convaincu
qu'ils vont vouloir les protéger
farouchement pour deux petites choses
avant de vous laisser aller le celi
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça c'est
une bonne mesure pour les familles qui
veulent avoir accès à la propriété le
soutien à la propriété tout une bonne
chose j'ai un regard très favorable
aussi sur les investissements qui sont
faits en matière de logement pourquoi
parce qu'il ya des gens qui en ont
besoin que moi d'avoir accès au savoir
faire une pression à la baisse sur la
spéculation que l'augmentation
déraisonnable de la valeur des
résidences temps au québec partout au
canada donc il ya eu quand même quelques
bons éléments à cet égard là l'autre
élément par contre on parle des gens qui
sont dans le besoin puis qu'un besoin de
logements abordables c'est le mépris
total du gouvernement dans ce document
l'homme qui dit qui va même faire un
petit tableau qui te garder les aînés
ont pas besoin de rien ils sont gros
durs les aînés même si une inflation
dramatique on leur rien de plus pour les
années dans ce budget là je pense qu'ils
vont le remarquer et françois blanchet
le votre drame dans la joute politique
c'est que pouvaient voter contre jeu
pendant dix fois avec l'alliance jeanne
[ __ ] vous êtes menotté pays a dû des
gouvernements majoritaires avant
maintenant que le bloc québécois des
juristes issus de gouvernement
majoritaire ont été moins pertinent pour
ça et je répète le bloc québécois ne
peut pas perdre politiquement soit on
demande des changements pour les options
ne fait des gains sont en demande des
changements qui sont ce que les
québécois veulent on les obtient pas les
québécois se met à réfléchir à leur
avenir dans tous les cas pour nous c'est
salutaire il françois blanchet merci de
nous avons parlé en tirait toujours un
plaisir au revoir
mais le dollar ça vient réduire votre
impôt tour de table madeleine
je commence avec vous le jeu politique
bien sûr depuis cette annonce quand même
faut le dire spectaculaire de cette
entente c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire ça paraît pas du tout
aujourd'hui évidemment non comme je
disais tout à l'heure on a l'impression
d'avoir gouvernement pratiquement
majoritaire lorsqu'on lit ce budget là
un gouvernement qui est pas pressé de
faire des décision d'envoyer des bonbons
aux contribuables parce qu'il sait très
bien qu'il est plus stable qu'il l'était
il ya quelques mois à peine cette
alliance avec le npd on a quatre budgets
devant nous là on vient d'en passer un
aujourd'hui en reste trois autres vous
cette entente devrait tenir évidemment
on peut pas prédire l'avenir là ça va
pas nécessairement duré tout ce temps là
mais on sent que ce mariage entre le npd
et le parti libéral d'un côté comme de
l'autre on veut
finalement de laisser une chance à cette
alliance là et je ne viens télé tellier
cette dynamique là au parlement à ottawa
change les relations inter provinciale
avec le grand au fédéral oui on en vient
de voir avec la déclaration de monsieur
blanchet justement c'était quoi ces
enjeux là faut pas oublier le wes non
plus puis même l'ontario alors comment
chaque province au pouvoir se
positionner par rapport au gouvernement
trudeau mais ce qui est intéressant dans
ce budget là c'est qu'il ya pas grand
chose sur laquelle se met là d'un jeu
france à l'ontario par exemple ou la
baule ici le secteur de l'automobile est
très intéressante on aurait pu penser à
des investissements importants pour le
développement des voitures électriques
il ya eu des annonces il y en a eu des
annonces j'aime bien quand même oui
exactement mais on sentait que c'était
assez poussées avec le gouvernement ford
alors on voit pas nécessairement un
leadership fort de la part du
gouvernement fédéral pomperait l'annoncé
un peu dans tous les dossiers pour
toutes les provinces donc comme je
disais tantôt un gouvernement
relativement centralisateur et
décomplexé par rapport à ce phénomène là
un gouvernement aussi je vous dirais un
petit peu plus centriste parce que
justement il coudées franches en ayant
cette alliance avec le npd peut aller
aussi regarder du côté de l'économie ce
qu'on l'avait pas vu faire depuis
plusieurs années à vrai dire c'est la
première fois que je vois un budget où
c'est plus la classe moyenne qui est le
moteur de l'économie mais bien
l'entreprise qui est le moteur de
l'économie c'est un nouveau discours
qu'on entend de la part de monsieur
trudeau donald frileux alors ça va être
intéressant à voir comment ça va se
développer comme si on avait enlevé
mi-homme gilles des pages et des pages
sur la classe moyenne et les ai beaucoup
de rhétorique là c'est comme si on était
revenu un budget un peu plus
traditionnel
mais c'est un budget moi j'ai trouvé
rafraîchissant parce qu'on faisait pas
notre trop d'enflure non plus à propos
tout ce qu'on a fait on est vraiment
ciblé les défis importants en termes de
productivité d'investissement privé les
enjeux du canada a besoin plus de
revenus pour pouvoir avoir des services
et caetera et donc moi je trouve que ça
fait du bien parce que ça permet aussi
d'avoir des solutions pour répondre à
ces changements la pile il ya énormément
de choses qui se passent dans le monde
avec la pandémie que l'invasion de
l'ukraine mais ça change toute la
logistique des chaînes de valeur une
transition énergétique qui s'accélère le
canada doit trouver sa position doit
être beaucoup plus proactifs
économiquement pour se positionner là
dedans puis c'est ça je trouve l'accent
du budget et c'est très bien parce qu'on
est très en retard tourne beaucoup de
travail à faire oui madeleine conclusion
monsieur trudeau il ce magazine quand
même des discussions difficiles non pas
juste avec québec mais avec les
provinces oui puis éventuellement elles
vont devoir venir ces négociations la
patrie ce parce que le gouvernement
trudeau a dit souvent lorsque la
pandémie sera terminée là on va pouvoir
se pencher sur la question de la santé
mais aujourd'hui dans le budget on a
l'impression que la pandémie elle est
derrière nous on a l'impression qu'on
n'est pas en train d'agir pour gérer
cette crise là mais pour plutôt pour
gérer les crises à venir productivité on
en parlait crise avec l'ukraine dont on
parle de finances militaire on parle
plus de programmes dead pour l'aco vide
donc les provinces peuvent avoir le
signal qu'elles vont pouvoir essayer de
négocier assez fortement avec le parti
et le parti libéral madeleine mis à
geneviève merci on se retrouve plus tard
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
mesdames et messieurs vous pouvez aller
sur notre site radio-canada paix
essentielle ment le canada demeure dans
le rouge jusqu'en 2026 27 on prévoit un
déficit de neuf milliards en 26 27 ça
peut changer deux fois quand même le
logement est peut-être la pierre
angulaire le nouveau compte celi où vous
pourrez pour faire un premier achat
mettre de l'argent on se retrouve au 17
heures merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh